- [Instructor] The server
suggests that all guests
would try the homemade
chocolate fudge cake.
Now, when I read this and
I had the word would here,
when I see the server
suggested all guests would try
the homemade chocolate fudge cake,
I'm expecting, well, under
what conditions would they try?
So I'm expecting to see
something, would try
the homemade chocolate fudge cake
if such and such happened.
But that's not what they're telling us.
What we're really saying
is that the server suggests
that guests try the homemade
chocolate fudge cake.
So I definitely don't wanna
keep it the way it is.
If we said tried, then that
would be the past tense.
The server suggests that all guests tried
the homemade chocolate fudge cake.
Now, that would imply that
the server's suggesting
that in the past, all the guests had tried
the homemade chocolate fudge cake.
But that's not the intent of the sentence.
The server's suggesting that people try
the homemade chocolate fudge cake.
So I'm gonna get rid of that one.
And I keep saying it, and we
see the best choice three.
The server suggests that all guests try
the homemade chocolate fudge cake.
This is exactly what we want.
The server is making a suggestion.
It's not a conditional, it's
not something in the past.
And then we can rule out
this last one, will try.
This is kinda the server,
if we replaced will try,
this would be the server
predicting something
about the future, which isn't
the intent of the sentence.
The server suggests
that all guests will try
the homemade chocolate fudge cake.
So I think this one is off too.
So definitely like that choice.